how did you lose your
weight um you didn't use that OIC did
you no I was um just I've been dieting
for a long time it's been like a steady
decline over the last two years but it
looks like it's it came like it seems
like miraculously fast like to know the
to see the difference I was losing like
10 lbs per month for like cuz I lost
like 70 lbs wow it was crazy I was at
two well I stopped measuring at 250 you
wouldn't take OIC would you I don't
think there's anything wrong with it I
do why because I just think that it's uh
I know somebody Jeremy do you mind
saying do you know somebody tell tell
the just give that little update all
well family M all messed sorry I'm just
going to keep them on yeah well go ahead
go a family members all messed up now
they got like migraines and shoulder
pain really I've heard really good
things about in the hospital hospital
they went to the hospital well I supp
listen all
medicine did you see that recently there
was a story that came came out that OIC
injured someone and now for the rest of
their life they can only have uh liquid
stool and not solid stool so they only
for the rest life how hold on there's no
way that story is true let look it up
you got to fact check that how can you
say oh you only get to have diarrhea now
like that's not a real thing you only
get to yeah no more solid stools for you
buddy well they haven't had a solid
stool since they took how can you
predict that though there's no way
that's you're a professional leader how
is that possible
what how is that possible wa wa wait
repeat what he were saying that you that
somebody is only allowed to have
diarrhea and no hard stools apparently a
doctor decreed that I I don't know yet
but but say it with authority I don't
know how that's possible see you heard
it here first I'm just but actually I
I'll push back because I think OIC is
actually uh almost seems like somewhat
of a miracle drug that's helping people
a lot and it's life changing or it's
life saving I feel like for for lots of
people well no obese people so there's
the one called
mouro it's the same drug but it's for
dear a woman suffers a life-threatening
bowel injury where did it go well all
medicine is going to have negative side
effects I mean all medicine diarhea die
from taking
ibuprofen
he